عندما ماراكا فاديمان أفينتادور ، إذا كان
سيكون دونالد ترامب في فاليتا بجنوب
كارولينا ، سوف
يغري الحديث مبكرًا بنظرية كاري
مانوج أمير المسلمين ، أنا في الدوحة ،
مؤتة ، تقول هيدا ترامب الآن
أنه لا ينبغي السماح للمسلمين  لدخول
هذا البلد حتى تكتشف الولايات المتحدة
ما يحدث ، هل توافق على ذلك ،
نعم ، أنا
لا أفعل هنا ، من يدري ما الذي
سيحضرونه في هذا البلد لقنابل
داعش ، ما الذي يحتاجون إليه للذهاب إلى من زعيم ليزا
دايموند وحيد أ
مختبر ترمب الكيميائي متذبذب من المسلم أمينة أمينة
أمريكا فيل كيف الناس أنا تاكونا في
التعديل الذي أجريته في الحديث ناما حونة ، لقد
قمت بعمل مقصلة الرجولة ، إنها
فكرة حكيمة للغاية وأعتقد أنه
بذل العناية الواجبة عندما يدلي بهذا
التصريح لدينا  لحماية
مواطنينا الأمريكيين أولاً وعملية الفحص
في البرنامج برمته تفتقر إلى
النزاهة شديدة القسوة أساهي هان املأ
ورقتها غدًا أميليا لتعلن
كابريرا في قبعة التلفزيون ياهو دا دا كونها
والطبيب  له في الصيحة الجراح
مسلم في أساهي باللون الأسود في المنزل
لاري يفعل في فندق جديد محمصة منشفة ساخنة
أبادو هوميرا دلهي لجنة MOT
أعتقد أنه يجب عليهم الخضوع
للفحص ، أعني
الفحص الشامل ، أعني أننا سمحنا
لإرهابي بالدخول إلى هذا البلد فعلوا
إطلاق نار في كاليفورنيا ، أقول عرضًا ،
إنه يقول فقط إنه لا يجب السماح لأي مسلم
بدخول البلاد في الوقت الحالي ،
فأنت توافق ، نعم سيدي الآن ، الأمر بهذه البساطة ،
نعم ، أنا موقع عمود الطوطم ، أداما
السبت ، أعني صاروخ الله إيرين إيرين
أندروز ، رجل لديه تمامًا
حددت مساواتنا ، فوكس والكر ، بالنساء
المعدني ، فلماذا تركت ذلك يحدث ،
عليك أن تمحو منازلهن من حيث
أتوا ، عليك أن
تمحو تمامًا هذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة التي
ستوقف بها الإرهاب ، هل تؤيد
قصف منازل الإرهابيين
بالتأكيد سيستمر الناس
في التكاثر
وسيربون الأطفال وفقًا لمعتقداتهم ، يحتاج شخص ما
فقط للذهاب إلى هناك
والسيطرة على هذا ، أعتقد أنه
إنه يتفشى وأنا قلق بشأن
أمريكا قلقة بشأن سلامتنا التي
يحصلون عليها ، يجب أن يتم إيقاف
PETA في شهر نوفمبر ، حيث ستعود سارة
كيلي ماتي إلى الفندق ، وعلينا
أن نذهب وسنعمل على
التخلص من  هؤلاء الناس لماذا
تعتقد أنه الرجل الذي سيواجه داعش
، لديه الشجاعة لتوليه
ويمكنه أيضًا بناء تحالف من
أشخاص آخرين لمواجهته أيضًا